can I help you y-yes yes you can I'm  here to report a terrible crime and what  terrible crime is that this one nah [ __ ]  I told this all wrong quick history  lesson this all started when the Joker  and I broke up  it was completely usual and soon enough  I was back on my feet ready to embrace  the fierce goddess within it's oh so now  that I cut ties with mr. J I'm about to  learn that a lot of people want me dead  alone at the top of that list  is this guy  but it turns out I wasn't the only  daemon got them looking for emancipation  the kid just robbed him you betrayed him  you killed his BFF what you are so cool  you're dumb enough to be building a case  against him so unless we all wanna die  very unpleasant death we're gonna have  to work together  sure  psychologically speaking vengeance  rarely brings the catharsis we hope for  yeah are we ready  oh [ __ ] is that a hyena in a bottle  named and bruised after that hunky wine  guy  [Music]